I want to bring these calls between
President Obama and president like Trump
directly to you the American people here
are some of the latest hello did you
hear who came to see me
at Trump Tower yeah Kanye was oh crap
what I kept calling him stupid dog it's
an acronym for Supreme Court of the
United States
what's it accurate in its a were made
out of first letters of a series of
words like how does President of the
United States it is I thought it was
another weird name you had like Iraq
what's the White House Rose gray boy
it's just a nice area often reserved for
press events okay what it's a little gay
I know West came to see me at Trump
Tower right what was that all about I
don't know
we shared a sandwich today the relative
silence so nothing came out of that
meeting
oh no he said Creek area of Agriculture
now planning my huge inauguration event
who did you get to perform at yours
Quincy in 2008 we had Stevie Wonder
YouTube Bruce Springsteen and Beyonce
and Beyonce came back in 2012 - those
guys are okay so who you got we got fur
babies for mobile stack and the
California
[Applause]
that would be great
you